Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
As we discussed before, simulating the motion
of fluids and smoke with a computer program
is a very expensive process.
We have to compute quantities like the velocity
and the pressure of a piece of fluid at every
given point in space.
Even though we cannot compute them everywhere,
we can place a 3D grid and compute these quantities
in the gridpoints, and use mathematical techniques
to find out what is exactly happening between
these gridpoints.
Still, even if we do this, we still have to
wait up to days, even for a few seconds of
video footage.
One possible way to alleviate this would be
to write an adaptive simulation program.
Adaptive means that the simulator tries to
adapt to the problem at hand.
Here it means that recognizes the regions
where it needs to focus lot of computational
resources on, and at the same time it also
tries to find regions where it can get away
with using less computation.
Here you can see spheres of different sizes
- in regions where there is a lot going on,
you will see smaller spheres.
This means that we have a finer grid in this
region, therefore we know more about what
is exactly happening there.
In other places, you also see larger spheres,
meaning that the resolution of our grid is
more coarse in these regions.
This we can get away with only because there
is not much happening there.
Essentially, we focus our resources to regions
that really require it, for instance, where
there are lots of small-scale details.
The spheres are only used for the sake of
visualization, the actual output of the simulator
looks like this.
It also takes into consideration which regions
we're currently looking at.
Here we're watching one side of the corridor,
where the simulator will take this into consideration
and create a highly detailed simulation - at
the cost of sacrificing details on the other
side of the corridor, but that's fine, because
we don't see any of that.
However, there may some objects the fluid
needs to interact with.
Here, the algorithm makes sure to increase
the resolution so that particles can correctly
flow through the holes of this object.
The authors have also published the source
code of their technique, so anyone with a
bit of programming knowledge can start playing
with this amazing piece of work.
The world of research is incredibly fast moving.
When you are done with something, you immediately
need to jump onto the next project.
Two Minute Papers is a series where we slow
down a bit, and celebrate these wonderful
works.
We are also trying to show that research is
not only for experts, it is for everyone.
If you like this series, please make sure
to help me spread the word, and share the
series to your friends, so we can all marvel
at these beautiful works.
Thanks for watching, and I'll see you next
time!